today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
all right it's uh it's sort of feeling
like fall here in massachusetts
which means that in an election year
it's probably
primary day because massachusetts will
sometimes have
very very late primaries and indeed
yesterday september 1st was primary day
here in massachusetts and it was
basically a good night
for incumbents we followed a lot of
these individual races which i'm going
to go through with you which had
prominent primary races in the senate in
the house of representatives we even
interviewed one of the candidates last
week
and overall if you were hoping to
see incumbents upset you did not see it
yesterday so let's go through some of
these races first and foremost we had
incumbent democratic senator ed markey
defeat challenger joe kennedy the third
joe kennedy the third of course
a congressman who is giving up his seat
in the house we'll talk about who won
the primary for that house seat a little
later
but ed markey winning solidly
55 to 44 with about 1.2 million votes
cast
but still i mean listen all that matters
is who wins in the end
but 44 for a challenger to an incumbent
democratic senator
in the state of massachusetts
particularly one who's relatively well
liked
is not nothing so you know it's like
that when you lose
you've lost and saying joe kennedy can
feel good about 44
it's kind of dumb feel stupid to say it
but this is not 80 20.
55 to 44 ed marky will
retain his spot at the top of the
democratic ticket and presumably
will be re-elected um in november i did
vote for marky i received questions
about this a number of times during live
calls and for me
what what it fundamentally came down to
was the case being made for why
kennedy should replace marky was not a
solid one for me there was the idea
that kennedy is more progressive and
when i looked at the issues particularly
on a climate and in other places
i just didn't see it and to say let's
remove someone who now has built some
seniority in the senate
for someone else basically for what
feels like the argument that he's
younger joe kennedy
39 years old and marky in his 70s
it felt like a weak case and so i
ultimately did vote for ed markey and
that's not a secret i mentioned that on
the program a number of times before
in my uh sort of former congressional
district because i
i don't live in that area anymore but
also the lines have been redrawn in any
case
my former congressman richard neal the
incumbent
uh facing a solid primary challenge
from holyoke mayor alex morse holyoke
massachusetts mayor alex morse
i met alex morris more than a decade ago
we interviewed him on the program when
he was running for and had won
the mayorship of holyoke massachusetts
he was also on the program
last week he did not prevail ultimately
the incumbent richard neal
won it it wasn't super close 59-41
again you can say great job by alex
getting 41
of the vote but it was not really close
there was polling going into this one
that said it was within five points
and the margin of error was a few points
there so you could argue that there was
polling saying that this was effectively
a statistical tie maybe but in the end
59
to 41 uh there and
richard neal will uh certainly be
re-elected
in november then we had a three-way race
for joe kennedy's vacated seat so this
is the democratic primary
for who will be on the ballot in
november
for joe kennedy's seat which he is
vacating
in order to run against ed markey losing
yesterday of course
and there an incredibly close race
jesse mermel just barely defeating jake
oschenschla austin kloss
22.4 to 22.3 now
that was only 105 vote margin incredibly
with becky grossman in third place with
about 17 and a half percent of the vote
and then we had incumbent stephen lynch
one of the more i think is fair to say
centrist democrats
in the house defeating challenger robbie
goldstein
that one even less close
than the alex morris richard neal race
lynch winning 66 to 34 which is very
close to a two to one margin
so that one was not close although
goldstein did generate
some level of interest and enthusiasm in
the district in
massachusetts now one other primary of
interest yesterday
there's this wacky conspiracy theorist
who was running for the republican
primary for the senate so this would be
which republican will be on the ballot
in november against ed markey
and this doctor ayadarai
is a doctor who falsely claimed to
to have invented email spread
disinformation about coronavirus
promoted unfounded covid treatments i
mean really like a wacky
i don't want to say alex jones-like but
certainly shades of alex jones
dr shiva lost the republican primary to
kevin o'connor
60-39 so o'connor will be on the ticket
against marky in november
now to give you a sense of of the
lopsided nature of massachusetts
uh even though republican presidential
candidates get in the high 30s to low
40s right so it's it's lopsided but you
still have a sizable republican
population in massachusetts
there were only 225 000 votes cast in
the republican senate primary
compared to one more than 1.2 million
votes
in the democratic senate primary and by
every indication ed markey will easily
defeat kevin o'connor in november but
you've got to vote
you've got to vote there's a reason we
don't go by polls and we actually
hold the elections near uh near my dad's
house
for the last several months i've been
driving by a house with a sign
that says dr shiva and i always
cringe when i drive past it i'm hoping
it's going to be taken down very very
soon but overall
some of the latest primaries leaning in
the direction of the democratic
incumbents
some more progressive some less
progressive
and we now know who will be on the
ballot uh in november
joe biden leading overwhelmingly here in
massachusetts some polls say
it's a lead in the 20s high 20s some
leads some polls say it's a lead in the
30s
for joe biden but we've got to run up
the score
every massachusetts voter should vote we
must run up the score and in fact
that's sort of what i want to talk about
next
i believe that i would be irresponsible
at this point
if i didn't come to you and say there is
an unfortunate reality there's an
undeniable reality that
if all else is equal if you can do it
safely
we're probably better off if you vote in
person in november
or uh hand deliver deliver your ballot
and
track it if that is if voting in person
is not a realistic or safe possibility
now
i don't want to encourage anybody to do
anything dangerous and
of course voting in person there can be
funny business
and voting by mail there can be funny
business but my
sense right now is that your vote is
more likely to be counted and counted
correctly
if you vote in person and we now have an
additional reason to suspect
that it is important to consider voting
in person if you can do it
safely of course which is that more and
more data firms are predicting that we
could have an extremely chaotic
situation where because we know
that those planning to vote in person
are more likely to vote trump
and those planning to vote absentee are
more likely to vote joe biden
there's a very good possibility based on
analyses by a number of political data
strategy firms including hawkfish
that we may well have a situation
where trump is slightly ahead
on election night and will almost
certainly claim victory
but as the biden absentee votes come in
in the set 24 48 72 96 hours
after election day joe biden may well
win now
we don't know that that's going to
happen biden might win
outright on election night and grow the
lead as
mail-in votes are counted uh trump may
win outright on election night
by a lot and then the margin might
shrink
as absentee ballots are counted and
trump will still win that's a
possibility
but hawkfish is now saying
and they have an upcoming interview on
axios on hbo which we'll see i believe
over the weekend
the ceo of hawkfish josh mendelsohn says
there is a scenario they are projecting
called the red mirage and the red mirage
is the idea of
a red victory on election day which will
merely be a mirage
which will evaporate right continuing
this mirage
metaphor as we approach 100
counting of ballots including absentee
ballots
at which point it may actually be joe
biden who has won
and it looks like it could take five
five or so days trump is talking about
we might not know the results for months
trump said we might not know the results
for years trump even said we might have
to
redo the election no that's not true but
it could be five days
uh five business days even which is
really like a week
so this is the scenario
that will most fuel trump claiming it's
rigged
if trump is ahead on election night and
really does fall behind after all the
absentee ballots are counted
trump will claim that it is rigged and
in fact
in the intervening period between trump
claiming victory on election night
as those ballots are being counted you
are likely to see two things neither of
which is particularly good
number one you are likely to see a wave
of lawsuits at the precinct level
at the at the county level at the state
level from the trump campaign
trying to stop the counting of absentee
ballots it may not work
and you won't see it everywhere but it
is almost
a certainty that if trump narrowly wins
on election night
i should better say is ahead on election
night electorally
because of small margins in a bunch of
states which is very plausible
that trump will do everything he can to
stop the counting of absentee ballots
using all sorts of different arguments
which we will talk about on a different
day
and of course those may ultimately be
decisions made by trump appointed judges
that's one thing that will happen if the
red mirage scenario
um is a reality the second thing that
will happen
is trump will claim victory and will say
they're trying to take it from me with
phony absentee ballots
and it is very plausible that this will
lead to violence in the streets from the
trump gun
people now i don't want to spend too
much time on that because we've
discussed it before
but this gets me to the position
that i would say i want to choose my
words carefully i believe that all
else being equal if you can do it safely
it's ideal to vote in person
and even vote early in person if you can
a lot of states have early voting
that would be the number one way vote
early and in person
fewer people usually voting early
shorter lines
then it would be vote in person on
november 3rd if it's safe if you're not
high risk i understand not wanting to do
that because of
the risk of coronavirus then it would be
mail-in but you de you hand
deliver the ballot to a ballot box and
then
fourth would be you just mail it in and
we hope
usps lawsuits don't stop the counting
whatever no matter what vote but this is
how i would sort of rank the efficacy of
those voting options a lot of what's
going on we just can't control
we're activating around stopping
destruction of the post office
the damage may have already been done by
louis de joy but ultimately we can't
really control it we can't control voter
intimidation
uh we can't control voter purges we
can't control foreign meddling we can't
control hacking of machines
individually i mean obviously we can be
activists to shine a spotlight on these
problems
we can decide how we choose to vote
and i am leaning towards some kind of
in-person voting ideally early
if not on november 3rd is probably the
best way to both
uh increase the likelihood our vote is
counted correctly
and decrease the probability of this red
mirage
scenario let me know what you think i'm
on twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one
sitting that's exactly what one of my
favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so there's been a lot of discussion of
if and when joe biden is going to
denounce
violence that is taking place in
different places around the country and
the trumpists and donald trump himself
have focused in a lot on this
why won't joe biden denounce this why
won't joe biden denounce that
now before we get to the sort of
substance
here which is that joe biden did it and
a lot of people on the left are furious
with him and the right is just simply
ignoring it
does joe biden really need to denounce
anything in the sense that
we currently have violence happening
under the leadership of donald trump
and even though donald trump is trying
to insist that violence is what's
in store in biden's america if you look
back at when biden was vice president
things were
relatively calm and the violence that we
are seeing now to the extent that it
exists
is a a lot of it is being done by trump
supporters of course not all of it but
it is all happening as donald trump is
president of the united states but okay
let's put that we'll table that argument
for now
and let's just say people want biden to
denounce
the violence well he did it joe biden
did it in a speech
in pennsylvania and trumpists are just
pretending that he didn't do it and some
of the left is furious so what i want to
discuss with you after we look at the
clip is
did this make sense let's take a look at
what joe biden had to say
rioting is not protesting looting is not
protesting
setting fires is not protesting
none of this is protesting it's
lawlessness
plain and simple and those who do it
should be prosecuted violence will not
bring change
it will only bring destruction it's
wrong in every way
it divides instead of unites destroys
businesses only hurts the working
families that serve the community
it makes things worse across the board
not better
no it's not what uh dr king or john
lewis taught
and it must end so on the
facts i agree with joe biden here
rioting is not protesting looting is not
protesting and setting fires is not
protesting in the sense that it will
bring productive change now i know that
there are people who will respond and
say
you don't get to set the terms of what
counts as protesting okay well we'll get
to that in a little bit
but the possible folly of joe biden
doing this is that the right is just
pretending he didn't do it they're
continuing to say
why won't joe biden denounce violence
even though he's done it
and there's a slice of the left that is
absolutely furious with joe biden here
now i'm not saying it's all the left or
a huge portion but
it's certainly a very loud slice of the
left particularly
online and the reason that some on the
left are mad at joe biden for doing this
is they say that he's playing into the
idea
that it's his supporters who are being
violent the the idea being
by joe biden coming out and saying no
matter who's doing it i'm against the
violence
it sort of frames it up as joe biden
acknowledging that it is his supporters
being violent
and telling them to stop uh i think that
there are two sides to this
so first of all i find it completely
reasonable and unproblematic that joe
biden says
violence is bad and i'm against it it's
insane
that it has to be said but he said it
and he said no matter who does the
violence i'm against the violence
but the second piece is that it's
important to clarify at every
opportunity
that almost nobody on the left is being
violent that a lot of the violence
is provocateurs and right wingers and i
hate to say this but
by and large the leftists that are being
violent
are overwhelmingly not people supporting
joe biden and often
individuals who see joe biden as as much
of a problem
or almost as much of a problem as donald
trump
so if there is a criticism of joe biden
here
it's that he arguably
indirectly or implicitly seems to be
acknowledging or conceding that some of
his supporters are being violent and i
really don't think that that's the case
at all i've not
really seen evidence of that so i don't
believe there's any problem with joe
biden
denouncing violence in principle i do
think it's sort of like when
you know there's an islamic terror
attack and right winger starts saying
why didn't this individual muslim person
who had nothing to do with it denounced
the violence well
most people denounce violence implicitly
most people are against violence i don't
know whether that
is even something that should be
expected particularly when joe biden
isn't in power
and there's no evidence that it is his
supporters that are doing anything but
what i would like to see more of
is joe biden aggressively placing the
blame where it should be placed biden
should be saying or let me go back there
are people saying
by doing this joe biden is hinting that
he's going to police and limit protests
as president
and limit free speech that's not at all
what biden is doing here and in fact
the obama biden administration had a
completely normal relationship with the
press
trump is the one that's authoritarian
and dystopian
when it comes to a free press and
ultimately this is a
sort of discussion of the martin luther
king
perspective on protests versus the
malcolm
x perspective and one of the things that
most resonates with me that dr king
often said was the problem
with going to looting arson violence
as a form of protest is not whether it's
morally defensible
maybe it is that's a perfectly
reasonable conversation to have
but the small percentage who choose to
do it
often end up hurting themselves and when
protests go to
violence looting etc it very often
backfires
and hurts the very people that we are
trying to help
through our activism that was this is
martin luther king's view
and you can extensively find interviews
with him on youtube where he says that
that's my take on it so on the facts
i do tend to agree with joe biden i
think the framing of biden must denounce
biden must announce he does
and they just keep saying biden must
announce as if he didn't do it
that's where it starts to get a little
problematic
so yesterday despite the fact
that the mayor of kenosha wisconsin said
don't come here
the governor of wisconsin said don't
come here
donald trump forced his way to wisconsin
and had a roundtable event now later i'm
going to tell you about some of these so
i it almost makes sense to call them
crisis actors that trump
brought in for this event but before i
get to that i want to actually play some
clips for you
of this completely toxic and pathetic
roundtable that donald trump did
which he started by saying everybody
maybe should look at taking their masks
off
take a look at this it's a great honor
if you feel more comfortable you'll say
a couple of words you might want to take
the masks off otherwise you can leave
them on
either way you want look how fast you
took that so again
the language of pandemic
we beat that that's over we got past the
pandemic
already taking masks off is something
people
may want to do here we saw it with 1500
people at his convention speech
no coveted tests no masks no social
distancing
we're continuing to see this attitude of
the pandemic is in the past it's not
really a thing anymore
trump then again using this analogy
about when police
sometimes choke and you would imagine
that after everything that's happened
including george floyd floyd and
including the debate over choke holds
maybe trump would have some other
metaphor to use here
but no and he also points out that he
feels very safe in wisconsin right now
jobs we can't be threatening them with
their pensions are going to be taken
away their job's going to be taken away
everything's going to be taken away
they're going to be
living a bad life if if they utter
an incorrect word you can't do it we
have to have our law enforcement we
cherish our law enforcement we wouldn't
be here without our law enforcement even
me i'm here today
i feel so safe and you went through hell
just a few days ago but i feel so safe
i better be safe i better be safe but
we're all safe and we're safe because of
law enforcement
and we honor you and i will say this
we have to condemn the dangerous
anti-police rhetoric
it's getting more and more it's very
unfair
you have some bad apples we all know
that and those will be
taken care of through the system and
nobody's going to be easy on them either
and you have people that joke they're
under tremendous i said it yesterday i
said it last night
they're under tremendous pressure so
trump kind of floated this idea in that
strange interview with laura ingram that
he did on sunday night i believe it was
or no wait actually it was monday night
where he said you know
sometimes police choke sort of like when
you miss a three
put a three foot putt in golf which was
not the most
fine-tuned and delicate analogy that
maybe he could have done
and particularly in light of george
floyd and everything else
choking is probably not the word i would
be using
attorney general william barr one of the
most extreme
sycophants that we've ever seen hold the
position of attorney general
traveled to kenosha with donald trump
and
insists that the violence that happened
after the jacob blake shooting was not a
legitimate response
to a police shooting take a look at this
that erupted
shortly after the shooting is simply not
a legitimate response
to a police shooting and the looting and
the
arson were unacceptable and as it
progressed it became more and more
distant from the issue of racial justice
it was violence for violence sake
so again i don't think there's anything
wrong with saying
looting and arson are not acceptable
forms of protest there are people who
think that they are
i happen to disagree and i think that
they are counterproductive forms of
protest more importantly but
notice that william barr didn't condemn
kyle rittenhouse who has been charged
with homicide
trump didn't condemn kyle rittenhouse
and in fact
increasingly the right is making him out
to be a hero
so it's not so much about bar is wrong
by criticizing arson
it's that just focusing on arson
by leftists is number one completely out
of sync
with what is actually happening on the
ground and number two ignoring more than
half of the story
donald trump was asked whether he thinks
police should wear body cameras this is
super interesting because what we're
seeing time and again is
trump is devoid of substance trump is
unable to discuss substance
an actual policy he just can't do it and
here trump is asked about body cameras
he just hems and haws he literally gives
no answer because he can't do not wear
body cameras
should every police officer in the
united states wear a body camera
body cam
well that's very interesting
let me ask bill to answer that question
this is what it looks like
when your brain is mush trump is unable
unable to discuss actual policy
substance even when it's a simple
question
just bails out and asks somebody else to
help him with the answer
there was another instance of this an
attempt to get donald trump to talk
about substance the question was
very simple question do you believe
systemic racism is a problem in this
country
and donald trump just doesn't answer and
says oh we should be talking about
protests
we're focusing on violent uh actions but
there have been
countless non-violent protests here in
wisconsin and across the country this
summer
uh people calling for an end to systemic
racism do you believe systemic racism is
a problem in this country
well you know you just keep getting back
to the opposite subject we should talk
about the kind of violence that we've
seen
in portland and here and other places
it's tremendous violence you always get
to the other side well what do you think
about this or that the fact is that
we've seen tremendous violence and we
will put it out very very quickly if
given the chance and that's what this is
all about
yeah i keep hearing about peaceful
protests i hear it about everything and
then i come into an area like this and i
see
the town is burned down i mean you look
at minneapolis
he just cannot answer it or he won't
answer it the question was not about
violence
in portland the question was simply do
you think systemic racism exists
this is maybe breaking news to some
people you can
simultaneously hold the beliefs uh
that arson is bad and
that there is reason for people to be
upset because of systemic racism in the
united states
you can hold that view you can now
whether trump
holds it or doesn't or is not willing to
say it that's a different question
there was a second attempt at basically
the same question
about systemic racism and systemic
change
trump still unable to answer it
my question was say it again the
peaceful
that have happened you're gonna have to
speak up so they're the peaceful
protests that have happened you've
acknowledged some of them
are peaceful they're calling for
structural change mr blake was shot
i think seven times in the back do you
believe that there is a need
for structural change what is your
message well i think people are calling
for structural change and then you could
take the people of kenosha
that aren't here and that you won't see
and that aren't protesting but they want
change also they want to see law and
order
that's the change they want they want
law and order just
cannot or will not acknowledge or
or even answer questions about systemic
racism
and aaron rupar on twitter asked a good
question
which is what's the point of these trips
to places like kenosha
he flies in meets with groups of
carefully selected sycophants
holds a round table where everybody
praises him and then flies back to dc
aaron arguing on twitter yesterday that
it's a complete waste of time and money
i i would say something else it's
actually counterproductive
when the local officials don't want you
there remember that the mayor of kenosha
said don't come here
the governor of wisconsin said don't
come here the owner
of a business that burned down refused
to participate
in the photo ops and they brought in
someone else to be photographed with
trump
as if they were the owners of this
business i'm going to talk about that a
little bit later but in the meantime
remember that you can
follow us on instagram at david pakman
show and remember that this program is
mostly funded mostly funded by
individual members
who sign up at joinpackman.com if you're
enjoying the programming consider
supporting us
with a membership it's quick it's easy
and it takes under a minute to sign up
at joinpacman.com the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right so yes we have to talk about
it the donald trump's health story has
gone
mainstream and i want to be really
careful with the story because
donald trump is denying something that
has not actually been
alleged and that is extremely suspicious
but i don't want to be alleging that
thing i think you're going to understand
momentarily here so over the last
several years
there have been general health concerns
about the president
what's going on with his cognitive state
you've got these twitches and spasms
that coincide with verbal glitches
you sometimes have upper trump and
sometimes downer trump he often seems
confused
he sometimes slurs without a real
explanation
we've seen him dragging his right leg
while walking
we've seen donald trump sort of unable
to just
speak normally talking about the oranges
of an investigation
and so on and so forth and then we had
in 2019
that abrupt visit to walter reed
hospital which we were told
was merely trump deciding on on a
weekend
that he had a few extra hours in his day
so he would show up at walter reed and
get a job
didn't pass the sniff test at the time
well
there is a new book coming from new york
times reporter michael schmidt
which says that visit to walter reed
was not trump saying let's get a jump on
my physical
that it was some kind of
abrupt visit due to something medical
that happened with donald trump
and it was serious enough that vice
president mike pence was told
trump may need to be put under
anesthesia be
on standby in case you need to take over
for some period of time those are the
allegations from michael schmidt
so the suspicions always were trump
wasn't there for his physical and the
book
claims to corroborate that now
um this would not be typical if donald
it wouldn't be typical for mike pence to
be put on standby
in case trump has to be put under
anesthesia if trump's really going for a
physical that wouldn't be normal for
a physical so that's so far okay there's
been an
allegation made that that visit was was
some kind of medical
incident donald trump tweets out of
nowhere
that he hasn't suffered many strokes now
you might say
why is trump tweeting about many strokes
michael schmidt didn't say anything
about many strokes well that's exactly
the question donald trump tweeting quote
it never ends now they are trying to say
that your favorite president
me went to walter reed medical center
having suffered a series of mini strokes
never happened to this candidate fake
news
perhaps they are referring to another
candidate from another party
now this is disinformation it has not
been alleged that trump has been
suffering many strokes
let me be clear people on twitter have
alleged it but
the point is it is not part of michael
schmidt's forthcoming book
that trump suffered many strokes trump
is out of nowhere
saying that something didn't happen
which no one has alleged this would be
like
if someone went to the hospital and you
say hey
did you go to the hospital for uh
routine blood work or did something
happen and you say
i didn't have a heart attack i
definitely didn't have a heart attack
it would raise suspicion if you start
denying something that wasn't alleged
and in fact it raises
more questions than it answers now i got
an email from
daniel who's a viewer who says my mother
is a board-certified
neurologist i showed her a few clips of
trump's foot dragging slurred speech etc
and she was fairly certain he had a mild
stroke recently possibly the night he
was rushed to walter reed hospital
so when presented with some of the video
uh of trump you can certainly find
medical professionals who would
who would ask about something like a
stroke but it is not
actually what the book alleges now we
also regularly see video as is mentioned
in the email
of donald trump walking and kind of
dragging his right foot
not picking it up completely as he walks
it is true that such video
exists but again it is not proof of
anything
so here's my take on this we should be
careful not to claim
anything happened when we don't know
that it did
yes the visit to walter reed was weird
yes it never passed the sniff test that
trump was getting ahead on his 2020
physical
yes trump bringing up strokes when they
haven't been mentioned
is extraordinarily odd uh but we really
need to get actual answers about why
donald trump went to the hospital
and um if it was for a physical there
would be no reason
that he would be placed under anesthesia
that that he would be
expected to go under anesthesia and
there would be no reason for mike pence
to be told
be at the ready so it is gaslighting for
trump to deny having a stroke because it
hasn't been alleged
and yet it is suspicious that trump is
focusing in on strokes particularly
since it's not something that has been
mentioned so it would be great if at
some point
because i do think that as a general
principle
the voting public has a right to know
about the real health status
of people who may be arguably the most
powerful people in the world
or among them i do think the public has
a right to know
and the white house should just come
clean about the reason for that visit
adding fuel to the fire of suspicion is
that when asked about this
mike pence's answer was
it was certainly squirrely slippery let
me put it that way
and that's what i want to talk about
next so in the last 24 hours
we have seen these allegations made
coming out of michael schmidt's
forthcoming book
that when donald trump was rushed to
walter reed
medical center in 2019 it was not that
he decided to get ahead on his 2020
physical
we suspected that from day one because
it didn't make any sense
but michael schmidt is saying that
something medical was taking place
and that it was serious enough that mike
pence was told
in case trump has to be put under
anesthesia be on standby be ready to
take the helm
uh as as temporary president of the
united states
so donald trump raised without
uh uh prompting that he didn't really
have a stroke
on that day now that was weird because
it hasn't been alleged that trump had a
stroke on that day but let's put the
trump piece aside and focus on mike
pence now
mike pence was interviewed yesterday on
fox news by brett bayer
brett bayer to his credit asks the
simple and straightforward question
is it true that you were put on standby
in case donald trump had to be put under
anesthesia that day
the answer does not inspire confidence
take a look at what mike pence had to
say
another candidate from another party
this refers to
michael schmidt's book where he says the
president went to walter reed which in
fact happened in november of last year
he says in the book that you were put on
alert to take
control to take office essentially if he
went
under for anesthesia is that true
president donald trump is in excellent
health
and uh brett i'm always informed of the
president's movements
and whether it was on that day or any
other day
i'm informed but there was no there was
nothing out of the ordinary
about that moment or or that day and i
just refer any other questions to the
white house physician but as far as
being on standby
so the question is were you put on alert
in case trump needed to be put under
general anesthesia
and mike pence doesn't say no mike pence
says trump is in excellent health
i'm always informed as to where trump is
and what trump is doing
and nothing out of the ordinary took
place and go talk to the white house
doctor about how healthy donald trump is
not an answer that inspires confidence
in fact when i hear mike pence say
anything but no
what i'm hearing is yes but brett bayer
tries again
take a look at what happened as far as
being on standby
i don't i don't recall being told to be
on standby
i i was informed that the president had
a doctor's appointment
and uh i don't want to say i must say
but i just want to yeah i i got i got to
tell you and
part of this job is you're always on
standby as your vice president of the
united states
um but the american people can be
confident
that this president is in remarkable
good health
and uh every single day i see that
energy and high relief
i want to talk about i don't recall
being told
to be on standby says mike pence
if you know how politicians lie and
avoid answering questions
this is mike pence making it a semantic
linguistic argument
he doesn't recall being told
and the word used was not stand by
that's what mike pence wants us to
believe and then he goes back to this
refrain
of trump is in great health these are
not denials my friends
if i had to sum up what mike pence is
saying if i run what mike pence is
saying
through a politician uh uh
decoding device mike pence is saying
yeah that's what happened and i don't
want to talk about it no
sane person could realistically watch
that answer
and think that mike pence is answering
truthfully
if someone is asked a yes or no question
and they talk and they talk and they
talk without answering the question
then the most likely answer is the one
that would be most embarrassing which in
this case would be
yes it is true we lied trump didn't go
to walter reed for a physical
trump was abruptly rushed to the
hospital there was the possibility
general anesthesia would be needed
and i was briefed to be on alert for
that
he starts the answer with the biggest
lie think back to that he is asked
about whether this took place and he
says the president
is in great health we know that's not
true
donald trump is obese he's medicated for
high cholesterol and he eats a terrible
diet of fast food
and doesn't exercise so it starts with a
completely
obvious lie and gets worse from there
so we should continue to be careful
not to make specific assertions about
what happened
when these are not the allegations that
anybody with insight is making
so when trump denies that he had a
stroke we shouldn't say
oh he definitely had a stroke but it
should raise our suspicion because it
hasn't been alleged
trump is the one raising the idea of a
stroke
and that's what's the biggest red flag
here let me know what you think
i'm on twitter at dpakman what do you
make of donald trump's tweet
denying he had a stroke which had not
been alleged and mike pence
refusing to answer the simple question
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter
at deepakman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well
read about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay so let's now get to this just crazy
dishonest story from kenosha wisconsin
where where the term crisis
actor which is often a staple of
right-wing conspiracy theorists
it almost works in this story take a
listen to this
so yesterday donald trump went to
kenosha wisconsin
the mayor didn't want him there the
governor didn't want him there this was
the site of unrest over the weekend
uh last week in fact and uh this is the
location where 17 year old kyle
rittenhouse was involved
uh in shooting multiple people killing
people
and ultimately charged with homicide
this is the place this is the epicenter
and it turns out that there was a
business burned down
in kenosha which is a century-old
camera shop and it's owned
by tom graham now tom graham that's
g-r-a-m
not g-r-a-a-h-a just tom graham g-r-a-m
tom graham was invited to participate in
a photo op with donald trump
um in front of the burned down shop
and he refused he refused because he
realized he was going to be used as a
political
prop and he said i'm not going to
participate in that
but if you watched the event it
certainly seemed like the owner
of that camera shop was there uh
and the reason is that they brought in a
different
guy they brought in the previous owner
of the camera shop they got a stand-in
they got a guy to
act in this crisis as if it has hit
as if it was his business that burned
down
if you look at the picture you see john
road now it's road camera shop so that
makes sense right well no
because john road hasn't been the owner
of road camera shop
for eight years check out this video
from the event
so this store was here 109 years
just about the oldest in the nation
doing work
in the state for sure that's fantastic
and we're going to help them
a lot i think we're going to help them a
lot would you like to say something
i just appreciate president trump coming
today
everybody here does we're so thankful
that we got the federal troops in to
help because once they got here
things did calm down quite a bit and our
city uh
police and sheriff and fire departments
are awesome
they worked harder than you can believe
24 7.
that's true this gentleman did a
fantastic job
working with the federal government and
it was really
great and once we said let's go
that was the end of it unfortunately
they had a few days
when people wouldn't call us they didn't
want to have us come in they just don't
want us to come in
and then destruction is done a day early
we would have saved your store
one day earlier one day early yeah
except
it's not actually this guy's store
the actual owner immediately refused to
participate
saying quote i think everything he does
meaning trump i think everything he does
turns into a circus and i just didn't
want to be involved in it
and he watched on tv tom graham saw on
tv
trump show up and talked to the former
owner
and saw john road commend donald trump
in his response to the unrest in kenosha
and uh congratulate trump for
sending in troops and all of this other
stuff
is this a crisis actor and i'm not
really saying it
i mean okay it's a term that right-wing
conspiracy theorists love to use when it
doesn't apply
when we had the horrible horrible
shooting
school shooting uh at sandy hook in
connecticut
you had alex jones and others talking
about these are crisis actors there are
no real victims so on and so forth i
think ultimately alex jones had to
backtrack on that because he got sued
but many others were saying it as well
crisis actors is a phrase a term that
they love to use
that actually seems to be a term that
applies
in this particular case and uh it has
not been this guy's store for eight
years and yet he has presented as if it
is his business that has burned down
now tmj4 news reached out to the white
house
to ask why did trump claim
that that was the business owner when
that is not the business owner
and the business owner in fact opted out
of participating here
they have not yet responded with a
comment and i am sure
that they either will not respond or
will come up with some justification as
opposed to saying
we made a mistake why because donald
trump has never said
that he has made a mistake and it is all
in continuing with the so earlier in the
show
i read a quote from aaron rupar who i
follow on twitter and he posts a lot of
great content
and aaron said what exactly is the point
of these visits to places like kenosha
the authorities don't want the officials
don't want trump there he just shows up
and meets with sycophants and pretends
that everybody is just so grateful for
him and then he leaves
that is the point and when you see this
case where the actual owner of the
camera shop said keep me the hell out of
it
and they get the guy who hasn't owned it
for eight years to stand there with
trump
it is all optics it doesn't the truth
doesn't
matter from the point of view of the
image that donald trump is
trying to create what matters is can you
find somebody to praise me
that's what trump cares about and that's
exactly what they did here
hey this is really crazy video that
people are up in arms about because it
is just so
whacked out this is video from july 31st
so the video is a month old little over
just over a month old
but it somehow flew under the radar
until yesterday
donald trump did a round table on july
31st with the national association of
police organizations leadership
as a protest of uh as as a sort of
counter programming when protests of
police brutality
were raging in the united states at the
time
and very similarly to
trump's recent statements about what
happened in kenosha
about what's going on in portland trump
at this event
generalized that the protesters are the
violent anarchists
and they are determined to assault
police officers police officers are in
danger police officers are the victims
despite of course being the ones who
hold the power
in the power dynamic that exists with
law enforcement
and trump went off on a tangent about
protesters throwing things frozen
bottles of water
bricks whatever and then trump went into
a one-minute long bizarre attack on
cans of soup and bags of soup
what what the hell is a bag of soup the
video
somehow slipped under the radar back on
july 31st
it is something else take a look at this
it's water
and then they have cans of soup soup
and they throw the cans of soup that's
better than a brick because you can't
throw a brick it's too heavy
but a can of soup you can really put
some power into that right
and then when they get caught they say
no this is soup for my family
they're so innocent this is soup for my
family
uh it's incredible and you have people
coming over with bags of soup big bags
of soup
and they lay it on the ground and the
anarchists take it and they start
throwing it
at our cops at our police and if it hits
you that's worse than a brick because
it's got force
it's the perfect size it's like made
perfect
and when they get caught they say no
this is just
soup for my family and then the
media says this is just these people are
very very innocent
they're innocent people these are just
protesters
isn't it wonderful to allow protesting
no
and by the way the media knows it better
than we do they know what's going on i
don't know what's wrong with them
they're doing our country so the extra
component of
bags of soup is just extra funny it
reminds me of when trump
in one of those montages for the rnc
interviewed workers who had recovered
from covid and
one worker said i'm a custodian at the
post office and trump said oh oh
what what do you do and it was just one
of these moments where trump is just so
out of touch where he doesn't understand
what what a custodian does
you know most people who grew up in
normal childhoods know what a custodian
does
it does or you know did uh particularly
if
you're proficient in english and this is
a similar moment where trump throws in
bags of soup now i have seen pouches
manishevits you can get a sort of
pouch of the dry ingredients which then
you mix with water
but i don't know that trump is talking
about those manishevits pouches when he
talks about bags of soup but
listen i guess we have to take seriously
the weaponization of soup i've always
actually been a little suspicious
of so-called alphabet soup that sounds
weird to me i don't know that that that
seems a little bit dangerous to me uh of
course you can only
bag certain soups like a bisque probably
does not lend itself to being bagged
but i've had a bag of chowder before
both manhattan and new england style
clam chowder really
really work well in a bag um this
actually
really is uh the exact type of
trump going somewhere in his mind where
we can't tell whether it's a joke or
something is wrong with him and of
course trump has no sense of humor so we
very quickly end up at like
something seems to be very very wrong
with this guy it's a delusional rant
about weaponized soup and then by the
way
worse than bricks like on the facts i
don't think that trump is actually
correct
and if you step back for just a moment
if this was your relative
wouldn't you immediately say they need a
full
nero psych eval like when we interviewed
dr bandy lee
i guess it was three weeks ago now two
three weeks ago
and she said you know the the symptoms
are there to warrant
a neuro psych eval doesn't mean you're
diagnosing anything but there's enough
going on where you would want that does
this qualify because this seems
very very strange and it would be weird
if it was anybody in your family it
happens to be the president of the
united states and as usual it's like
yeah people wrote to me about how funny
this
is it is funny it's funny in a
superficial way but
once we're the laughingstock of the
world and we're the pity of the world
it's not really all so funny anymore and
it actually hasn't been funny for a long
time will we ever know the full truth of
what is behind
rants like these does anybody after the
fact say hey mr president you know
sir as he likes to say the material
about weaponized bags of soup
that was not so good that doesn't really
resonate with people with people
my belief at this point given what we
know about trump's personality
is that the people around him aren't
willing to go up to him and say that we
know that anybody who's willing to say
to trump what you're saying doesn't make
any sense
they don't last very long and we've seen
more than 500 people
move on from this administration over
the last four years i just don't think
it's welcome at all
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here is a voicemail
inquiring about exactly the scenario
that i outlined earlier for election day
and election week take a listen to this
hola david thomas from chile here
i'm thinking the most likely scenario on
election night is that trump will
declare
victory because most republicans will
vote in person
and most of their votes will have been
counted by that
by that point uh thinking democrats will
have their votes
counted in bases another weeks after and
trump will call fraud potentially
leading to some violence
how how can we even prepare for
something like that
so listen let me get to the preparation
in a second but yes what tomas is
describing here
is the red mirage hypothesis the red
mirage hypothesis will be
since we know that we're going to have
um
so so the people planning to vote in
person are mostly trump people and the
people planning to vote absentee are
mostly biden people now the
the exact proportions will determine
whether this happens but it is a
completely plausible scenario
that trump seems to eke out some victory
on election night
claims victory and then as absentee
ballots continue to be counted i don't
think it will take weeks but it
certainly could take five days
the lead for trump shrinks shrinks
shrinks until ultimately joe biden takes
an electoral lead
and you were completely correct tomas
that that is a scenario
ripe for real world violence
and so the question about how to be
prepared for it is twofold
first of all police departments and
national law enforcement federal law
enforcement
need to take seriously the possibility
of not
protests of overwhelmingly unarmed
individuals
but angry weaponized trumpists
with firearms taking to the streets
that's a law enforcement question
the political question is we know
because trump uh has said that they're
going to do this and people around trump
have said they've got an army of lawyers
ready to go
we know that if this scenario happens if
trump seems to be ahead on election
night
with a lot of absentee ballots still to
be counted
immediately they are going to file
lawsuits to try to stop the absentee
ballots from being counted they are
going to try to say
they've got to be in by by midnight
election day or they've got to be in by
the next day but you can't just keep
counting absentee ballots
whether they will get away with it i
don't know but democrats
and joe biden's campaign need to have a
proactive plan for how they are going to
fight that in court now unfortunately
when trump brags he's put in place
is it 200 something 300 judges at this
point
it may be some of those judges who end
up deciding
in some states do the absentee ballots
continue to be counted or not
so it is a very serious scenario and i
don't know if democrats are going to be
prepared if history is an indicator
democrats may well not be prepared for
that and that's very very scary
on the bonus show today we are going to
talk about the pandemic remaining the
top issue for voters going into november
and what effect that is likely to have
depending on what happens with the virus
in the next eight weeks
we're also going to talk about calls to
end open carry of firearms period as an
institution
and lastly jacob blake's father is now
receiving death threats
jacob blake of course is the young man
who is now paralyzed
after being shot in kenosha wisconsin
and now his father is the one receiving
death threats it's unconscionable
and we will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
become a member get instant access at
joinpacman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video